I'm Miguel I'm based in Frankfurt I do
risk management consultancy and today
I'm going to talk about a bit tools that
we aren't currently not using in the
center in the field of risk management
but maybe and I'm making the case that
maybe we should use them so as I said
I'm currently doing risk management
consulting also doing part-time MSC so
if any new olean's like net likes
network models I find them really cool
and I'd like to talk about them as well
and I I'm a tinkerer I like to try out
new things and see how it play out and
this is from this tinkering that's where
this talk is coming from my background
is a bit more technical I i did some bi
for a trading platform and I have a PhD
in robotics speech from robotics the
company that I currently work for it's
based on three pillars so lots of
mathematicians lots of physicists so we
know a bit about the the quantitative
side and we then specialize in the
integration of the quantitative side in
the IT and playing around with the with
the needs of our clients and these needs
are very very related to processes and
regulation and governance so let me
start with a story this story this is a
true story this company had a to risk
systems and they wanted to try to figure
out whether combining the results from
these systems would lead to a reduction
of risk and of costs systems these
systems were specialized one was for the
IRS part so interest rate swaps and the
other one was dealing mainly with fixed
income so listed versus OTC and
the setup of this story is there was
there have been a huge effort in
implementing a software they have been
specified have been analyzing it in a
small scale and the question now is now
the software is ready does it really
deliver what it promises so we have to
near productive systems that we have to
combine with share with each other and
configure and try to figure out whether
the outcome is actually as expected so
we started by identifying large fixed
income portfolios this was in an Oracle
database then we computed the
sensitivity to interest rate changes the
dvo one this was an in exle then we went
to the other side and gathered some some
standard trades got there devia ones and
then combine these in excel in order to
get standardized trades that we could
use in order to set up the systems then
I realize that I had to generate some
XML so I emailed some files to my to my
laptop i generate xml files I then
uploaded them individually on the
training system then we got some results
so we had to trading systems we had some
risk results they were in oracle
database we copy them to axel we
evaluated the results and then in the
end you have some basis or some basis
for a management decision in PowerPoint
so the this was this was a one-off but
it's not very far away from the
challenges that you face when you're
dealing with these kinds of models and
it kind of boils down to a set of things
so risk management is hard not because
the bubbles I've really really
complicated but because each of the
parameters of models is very complex so
there's a lot of special cases so think
about calendars and then counting
conventions and then in the institutions
are in the systems that these figures
are being computed these are systems
that are being applied productively so
they're not really flexible and they're
not meant to communicate with each other
because this institution will have a lot
of different systems so data is spread
and if you want to analyze this data in
a non productive way then you have to be
really flexible and you have to make a
lot of assumptions on how you do the
computations because if there's no way
that you're going to be able as with
your excel sheets or whatever they
you're going to compete with the
productive system so you have to make
simplifications and in the end most
decisions are only based on these
simplifications so so there is lots of
sides to this so this is I think this is
a short coming there's lots of sites to
this and one of the sides is software in
my opinion so could we have better tools
so what could concrete problems so we
have the classic problem of not
separation of business logic and data so
this is a chrome that you have in the
most common software axle you have
different data sources not meant to
communicate with each other you have and
this is true this is for example if you
think about the pie the Python community
there is no psychic finance or something
there's a lack of out-of-the-box
functionality and easy to integrate and
in the end because you have all of these
then you have some other symptoms which
are you cannot reproduce most of the
work flows are much much of the most of
the analysis that you will be doing and
these are up
coupled with very hard very large
efforts so in the end you actually paid
to make very good educated guesses on
given the goal of your analysis to
figure out the best way with your
limited resources to get the answer to
the question and it's 2015 right should
we why do we still have these problems
this this happened last year now then
thinking about why is this so and in my
mental map there their main reasons
behind people using the tools and the
software that they're using so the first
one is the software is available this
this seems like a no-brainer but it's
related to the deployment problem so
this is a real real challenge the second
one is functionality can the tool even
if approximately deliver the compute the
things that I want to them that I wanted
to compute and then there's a social
part so can I can I collaborate with my
colleagues can I give them intermediate
results okay sorry so can you
collaborate with with with your
colleagues so can I give you
intermediate results and will they be
able to continue with the work that
you've that you've been doing and in the
end if you have them some results you
have to share them and will the people
be able to use the results that you have
been producing and then I looked into
though obviously there's there's other
parts to software but given the current
PI data ecosystem tool and unbiased to
data to to python and that's the reason
why I came to PI data but I think that
they're very interesting tools coming up
and I think that they have a place maybe
in a risk management
and set up to solve the to address the
four main reasons that I've mentioned so
you have the availability might be
solved by so you have anaconda as a
distribution you have Jupiter with the
notebook that every everyone is using
you have blaze that I find very
interesting to transfer data out you
have bouquet to show the results and you
have pandas and pandas delivers you a
set of functionality that is very very
interesting so again availability would
be covered by anaconda the functionality
by pandas and wit by plays with
aggregations and transfer collaboration
with Jupiter you would be delivering
your notebooks and letting people
continue and then sharing your results
again with with with Jupiter notebooks
and then making some nice plots with
okay so this is this was a setup this
was the the map that I've made two
reasons to the existing tools and I
wanted to explore this and I wanted to
do some in example and yes so I thought
of starting with the with the lowest
common denominator of risk models which
is valid risk so by it risk is a very
popular measure right because and it's
in addition to that it's very simple to
get your hand around your head around
and very easy to communicate and it
gives you kind of a boundary to the
losses within the given certain
confidence intervals for your portfolio
for a set of acids and a given time
horizon now right from malaria
regulatory point of view this is there's
a mathematical definition to this and
from the regulatory point of views this
is also very very interesting because if
this is one of the standard models that
has to be used by financial institutions
so I went and implemented this model in
a way that I could tinker a bit with
this model and produce a nice plots
so I extracted some risk factors and the
by the way the notebooks are available
online and you might might want to play
around with them and you know and just
looking at data I'm just extracting data
with the with blaze and then I will be
doing it something that is called the
filter historical simulation where you
look at your time series compute the
returns and then try to project the
returns in the future so your asset
price changes in the future in a way
that you abstract from the market
conditions at the point in time where
you measure them so you're filtering out
the volatility and trying to get a good
estimate on how how severe your losses
in the future it could be so I have a
moral I'm implementing the model and now
i'm going to play i want to play around
with it with the parameters to this
model so I've built some interactive
plotting with bouquet that is using both
blaze and both pandas functionality and
in order to do this I have a set of data
and I have to build something that is
called the column data source and this
is what this function is doing so I'm
building the column data for their
source I'm building a dictionary that is
being just a placeholder for some some
variables and then I have to build two
functions one that updates my model and
is doing a very important thing which is
pushing your data the data that you have
updated with the new parameters of your
model back to the notebook go back to
your plot so it's going to be updating
the plot
oh this was life
so in order to do the plot this is very
actually very simple you build a figure
object and then at different glyphs to
this figure object and here I'm building
two plots that I will show you now so
these are two the two plots just showing
my the volatility my log returns and
then the green line is the D volatilized
slug returns so there's for this filter
historical simulation there is there's
one main parameter to this and this is
well depending on how you estimate the
volatility it's the lambda the lambda is
determining how reactive you are to
changes in the volatility and now I can
go around and I hope this works and
change the parameters of my model I can
go to the standard configuration which
is point night for and you see the
volatility line so that the orange line
updating accordingly to my to my new
model so this is this is a very nice way
of if you have to communicate some some
some decisions or some seminars that
you've made you can not only deliver
some static plots and simply only by
programming python and building a widget
then you can actually give someone
something that they can play around with
and this is this turns out that this is
a very much much more efficient way of
communicating so now that I've extracted
my so to say my features I want to build
a predictive model and this predictive
model is just projecting the D
volatility d volatilize returns into the
future using my current volatility so
this is what this is doing and again in
my model my implementation which is just
couple of lines this sums up to these
two function calls
now now that you have to build some
predictions you have to look at how good
your model is so I and usually in order
to do this you do the back testing so
you go to given period of time and you
confront the predictions that you've
model has has delivered with the reality
there are standard ways of doing this
there's the cooperage proportional phase
test and like everything in finance
every result has to be mapped into three
colors green yellow and red that's basic
language of communication so I'm doing
something similar as it done with a
simple pot I'm doing making a pipeline
of a pipeline of computation in order to
update my model then I'm generating the
column data source so the bouquet object
that I can upload and feed to my plot
and then the plot creation I have two
plots that i initialize and they have
then to update the plots accordingly so
what I now have here is using the
functionality from the ipython widget
again a possibility of playing around
with the models that I have and seeing
how many outliers I have and you can see
that it is very significant to the
choice of lambda parameter that I have
and that whilst the models are actually
very simple the consequences of
configuring your model differently
they're very severe
so
when I was with when I did if this first
for the first time I wanted to do this
also and I mentioned that I wanted I
like to think of new stuff I wanted to
do the some stuff with spark and when I
did when I when I said that I wanted to
do some selves with spark my main focus
was actually in the performance so
taking the existing functionality that
you have so I KAG regaling large large
chunks of data and trying to beat Oracle
data sort data databases for this and I
had kind of an epiphany and I think that
this is the technology that is
interesting much more interesting for
other reasons and i'm going to go to
this reasons very soon in any case then
the reasons are the first one is the
scope right with the current tools that
you have and even staying with a pilot
ecosystem with the tools that I've shown
you have the possibility of doing
analysis on a very and a much broader
scope of assets portfolios so you can
stay with with simplifications on your
model but you can improve your analysis
by increasing the data that you have at
your disposal you can also use the the
available tools in order to especially
with place in order to span the gap
between different data sources different
systems and minimize for example ETL
processes and processes that run
overnight and take very long to run and
then when when you've overcome these
difficulties maybe you start thinking
about maybe you've guaranteed your
survival and maybe you start thinking
about different use cases different use
cases that you have and have the time to
think about
and although they are currently being
made being being being implemented
they're very costly entire in terms of
effort so one of the things is having
like an aggregated view on the risk
across the whole enterprise so you might
have different different companies
within within the group and maybe you
want to have an aggregated view on this
and the other thing is maybe you want to
build scenarios that you before that you
can really explore by because he didn't
have the the computing power to do this
and as you have spanned over different
systems you might want to change for
example like macroeconomic variables and
see how how would my company to how I
with my financial institution do if
there was a break in the GDP or pandemic
situation doing stress testing in a much
more realistic way that would be one of
the outcomes so why would be spanning
for example market risk credit risk
liquidity risk and trying to bring these
figures together in a meaningful way so
this is something where technology can
help obviously there are different
reasons why this is not being done so so
often our days there's governance issues
there is cooperation issues there's
simply also the complexity of doing the
risk measurements but maybe technology
can help you and spark I think is
something that is providing a hope a
glimmer of hope that we that that we can
do this that technology is not an
obstacle anymore because for example
Viet risk is very easy to simplify so
it's a relatively simple model it's very
easy to simply too paralyzed
and so it will be perfect for example
for mark we'd use but the models are not
that simple so spike gives you a bit
more than MapReduce and it gives you a
programming interface where you can
abstract from the data size to a given
complexity and gives you for example
something that is very important the
financial system which is or for
financial industry workers which is
support for SQL it also lets you use to
programming languages that are very
common with people that know statistics
like for example are and is at this
point in time evolving and enjoying
widespread adoption example IBM has
endorsed spark as their computing engine
of choice for the future so spike is
actually an ecosystem of tools and in
the end what they're doing is simply
bring these tools together with common
api's and this is very very very very
promising now so I wanted to evaluate
whether you could actually bring spark
to a financial context and I wanted to
evaluate this from the point of view of
computational complexity so this just
the complexity description so in a sense
would I be able to program a spark job
if I only have two days in order to do
this and different other problems to
tackle so how descriptive how powerful
is the spark what spark is is currently
offering so I have a very small toy
example here and
what I try to do was to take the results
from the previous model that I've shown
the previous implementation and try to
aggregate them so just just very very
very simple to example with very little
data and but let me go just briefly
through it so what we have produced with
the other model and we have been
evaluated is we have a set of scenarios
so now it's per day for example / risk
factor and we want to aggregate these
scenarios in order to get one view for
one day the first thing that I have to
do is parse the data source that I have
and I try it I wanted to do this in this
way saying that a risk factor scenario
is a risk factor ID a date a value for
my neutral scenario and then the narrate
containing scenarios this is where I
started having some trouble with sparks
limitations because I aggregation for
example results is currently something
that is supported only with a very
limited set of functions so there is no
custom aggregation of results so there's
no user defined aggregation functions so
i changed my data representation and the
data is in this format so you have the
risk factor you have the dates you have
the neutral zone I and then you have a
set of scenarios and I had to build the
type in a programmatic matter so this is
I do so this was first quirk that I with
it with a framework then I have to
define a parsing function because the
function is that the input spark is
going to read this as a line of text and
I have to transform the line test text
into something that is structured
and then after this beginning that the
nice part starts so I'm just programming
python here I'm reading text I'm parsing
it and then I am creating a data frame
which is a familiar object especially if
you know pandas the data frame doesn't
have a very human friendly appearance
and this is the first line but it is
nothing if in a way that I can aggregate
it so I can group by date and do the sum
of all other columns and spike figures
out which columns it can add in which
which which ones they can't for example
it will it will not add the risk factor
ID then I will map each of these grouped
each of these groups with with it within
with a lambda function and I'm
extracting the risk factor ID the date
and then I'm doing my very valid risk
calculation in the end I pack this into
a spark data frame again because this
was already d and then I get my figures
so this was it took me a time to get to
get through it but it was it's fairly
easy to understand once you've seen it
so it doesn't it's nothing compared to
what was like doing MapReduce jobs five
years ago then I try some slightly more
complicated case so I'm I'm defining a
portfolio which consists of a risk
factor ID a quantity and a portfolio ID
I'm going to do the same exercise and
now the third is the first thing that I
do is I have to join the scenarios with
my portfolio definition and this is also
fairly easy to do
the aggregation is a bit more
complicated but the group by operator is
very easy to work with so in the end
through very similar pipeline I can get
the results
so
in the end after doing this I have very
good feeling about about spark it really
gives you a way of abstracting from data
sources so I could simply get an RDD
from a text file or get an ID from a
database you can do jdbc connections or
simply get an idd to s3 or hive and then
work with it without being aware that
these differences exist so this is very
very important because i'm not i'm not
shuffling my data around in order to do
my jobs because in the beginning
currently if i want to do something
something complicated i have to get the
whole my data copied explicitly into the
same data source so if i have two
different databases i have to find a way
of copying data from one database to the
other database and then do the joint
work so spark is giving this possibility
of abstracting and then it's giving you
some programming objects that are very
familiar so it's giving you a data frame
it's giving you a possibility of
querying these data frames using sequel
and for me these are very powerful
constructs the spark delivers and I
wouldn't be very surprised if it's if it
delivers in Hawaii promises that being
said there's a wish list that i have
that would really help me convincing
other people in the financial industry
that spark is a way to go the first one
is being able to custom aggregation to
define custom aggregations that can also
work with with a sequel functionality
the second one is bringing more
functionality into the python our world
because most of it is currently inside
Java and Scala environments which are
closer to the JVM worst part
lips and very large problem is that
currently nobody it's difficult to get
around problems with memory and there's
there are no recipes or not clear ways
to tackle these problems and finally we
need more examples so we need to show
people how to do stuff whenever I when I
start tinkering with with it would spark
I could only find examples of word
counts so everywhere I looked there was
word count here work out there so this
isn't this is not really helpful and so
I decided to contribute a bit and give
this talk and maybe launching the idea
and maybe giving you the idea that
sparking spark is the way to go and I'd
like to finish with it with a quote from
Freeman Dyson that new directions and
science are launched by new tools much
more often than by new concepts this
effect of a constructor of the
revolution is to explain old things in
new ways the effect of a tool driven
revolution is to discover new things
that have to be explained and that was
my contribution thank
country girl questions from a girl
commits you mentioned you have the
notebook yep yeah sure we also to be we
will cite that will also be out gate a
little all the speed talks there's some
sort of get upholstery so there oh did
you guys have this video the whole time
yes do you need to have some things
right now I'm I was wondering whether I
just realized oh sorry it's because
sometimes of the screen is flip so
you're presenting on your screen there
that's showing you the present of you
for whatever reason ah you can see what
you can see the whole thing it's fine
okay I that's the first just quick
question I saw you are using free yep
yep yeah yeah no I don't like our it's
it's it's an important use case i will i
will try it sometime but unicode is one
reason for other other other projects
and the other reason it's it's being
developed of lee at the moment and I I
didn't have any problem when so he knows
what was the reason I'd switch then I
didn't have any problems and so I'm
thinking with it unique good yeah that's
good me that's going to make me very
very happy okay I constantly have a
season about his his zealotry towards
movie people towards part in 3.4 that's
a big win if you're gonna get is if it's
him alone that has pushed you towards it
the official i doubt PI data is that
everyone should be using Python 3.4 yeah
so now it's just great to be see it
being chosen anywhere else questions we
go
yeah yeah but not for aggregation as far
as I could get from the documentation so
you yeah you probably have to set up
each environment where you are you're
running the yup I hear your views back
jobs but that that is possible here the
last question everyone wants to ask one
know what is blink is a European okay
and how does it work from the from the
let's say from the complexity okay could
you explain could you let one non-tech
savvy user work with it okay so that's
that's that's my biggest that's my
that's the source of my biggest interest
in spark that people that don't
necessarily know the the inner workings
of an idd can actually do something with
it this is for me a very very very
important issue right well thank you
very much we go